you're about to hear words for me you've
never heard before I was dead wrong I
was dead wrong about this election I was
dead wrong that Donald Trump would not
win in the primaries I was dead wrong
that Donald Trump would not beat Hillary
Clinton in the general election I was
wrong that the poll data was reliable it
was not I was wrong the experts knew
what the hell they were talking about
with regard to ground game they didn't I
was wrong that the movement of which
Donald Trump bragged was just more
trumpian braggadocio rather than a real
on-the-ground mass phenomenon now I pray
fervently that Donald Trump proves me
wrong again about him as a human being I
didn't vote for Trump yesterday for all
the reasons I expressed yesterday on
this program I do not think Donald Trump
is a good man let alone a great one I'm
deeply concerned he's not conservative
I'm deeply concerned he'll failed to
fulfill his promises that he'll focus on
useless fights that he'll will engage in
counterproductive ones that he'll sell
out the people who voted for him I'm
concerned the Republicans justifiably
intoxicated by a victory over the Wicked
Witch of the West Hillary Clinton will
grant a halo effect to trump that will
allow him to engage in anti conservative
policies that will damage the country
and political foolishness that will
damage the conservative movement with
constituencies that conservatives are
still gonna have to recruit but I have
said for months that Trump could prove
me wrong I did say that he certainly has
every opportunity to do so now he enters
office with the majority of Republicans
in the Senate he enters office with the
majority of Republicans in the House he
answers with an open Supreme Court seat
a vast majority of GOP state legislators
a vast majority of GOP governors now is
the time for the vast change that we
were promised and that Donald Trump
promised to deliver this will require
Donald Trump to change as a human that
doesn't mean he should lose his fighting
nature at all obviously she'd keep
fighting the media it's the best thing
that he did the entire campaign I've
praised that part of him for years and
consistently throughout this election
cycle it doesn't mean he should stop
channelling the outrage of Americans but
bad people don't become better people
when they decompiler 'fl people and
Donald Trump was just handed the keys to
the car the leadership of the most
powerful country in the history of
humanity and the most powerful office in
the most powerful country in the history
of humanity will Trump feel freed from
the boundaries set on him by the
strictures of a presidential race will
he feel unshackled to be sort of the bad
Trump that we saw during the primaries
and during the general or will Trump
actually change as a human and be
elevated by his office will he
roll into the person that we all want
him to be write sincerely hope really I
hope that I'm wrong about him and that
it is the latter I plan to hold them
accountable if it's the former as I have
for the entirety of this election cycle
and consistently throughout my career I
will praise Trump when he deserves it I
will criticize him when he does not
deserve it for the sake of America for
the sake of conservatism I hope I hope I
have nothing but praise for presidents
elect Donald Trump I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show I think that's
the big news from the election by the
way is that that lives on for another
four years gang so if you like good
Trump bad Trump that sucker lives on and
we still continue not to pay royalties
to Brandon Snipes the creator of that
particular that particular diddy so
that's very exciting stuff a lot to get
to today did something happen last night
I missed it I did something there's a
basketball game right somebody won
somebody lost I just
people were saying something big was
happening and if I seem a little bit
tired today that's because we did an 8
hour broadcast yesterday we did a live
broadcast here at Daily wire calm and on
Facebook me and Andrew Klavan and Jeremy
boring and and Bill Whittle stopped by
for more time than he should have and
and some others stopped by as well is
steven crowder glenn back it was it was
a star-studded affair but it was it was
really it was really great fun and it
was fun to watch the race shift over the
course of the evening from Donald Trump
is going to lose to Donald Trump is now
going to defeat Hillary Clinton and
watching just the life blood drain out
of the faces of the people who love
Hillary Clinton watching as the universe
leached all meaning from their lives was
was really quite a Stephanie and in many
ways we'll get to all of that in the
side but first if you were looking at
the stock market today and the stock
market was down a lot today and you're
thinking hey maybe I should invest in
precious metals well you need to talk to
my friends at Birch gold birchgold.com
slash Ben is the place to do this if you
want to move some of your assets into
precious metals if you feel like the
market is inflated if you are concerned
that now that President Trump has been
elected president select Trump I'm sorry
president elect Trump has been elected
to the the president seats of the White
House if you're concerned that Barack
Obama on his way out is gonna have Janet
Yellen raise the interest rates to give
to give
from a bad economy and you want to
invest some of your money in precious
metals talk to my friends over Birch
gold group dot-com / Ben to move some of
your IRA or 401k into precious metals
ask all your questions get all your
answers and then work with the folks at
Birch gold group birchgold.com / Bennett
okay so here's the deal here's the deal
and there's so much to talk about
surrounding this election who are sort
of the winners and who are the losers
and what do conservatives do from here
because you know Donald Trump I have
hopes that Donald Trump with a
conservative majority is going to
actually do some very conservative
things I do have hope for that that's
gonna require Mitch McConnell to have a
spine and that is going to that's always
a dicey proposition especially when
there are apparently 51 senators that
means that he really has to hold his
caucus in check if you want Donald Trump
to get things done Mitch McConnell must
hold kind of weak need Republicans like
like what susan collins from maine has
to hold them in in check for sure that's
that's a very important thing but i want
to talk about first the biggest losers
last night so there are a lot of people
just to get this this kind of elephant
out of the room who say that never Trump
was the big loser
last night not really because I knew one
of these few people was going to be
elected and I didn't want it to be
Hillary and I didn't want it to be Trump
so I lost this election a long time ago
and last night if you watched the
broadcast I said I was feeling pretty
ambivalent I felt a little bit
manic-depressive every time we talked
about Hillary Clinton not being
president a smile crossed my face the
hilarity of Hillary Clinton spending her
entire life using whatever was left of
her soul in order to become President of
the United States only to lose to Donald
Trump a reality TV star after spending
her entire life standing next to a guy
who sexually abuses women after using
every element of government to corrupt
effect after perverting justice after
escaping justice after running 1,000
times for the presidency to win the
popular vote but lose heavily in the
electoral vote again to Donald Trump a
person that she and her husband told to
run it's like that's wonderful every
time I thought of that I just thought
somewhere Hillary Clinton is just tying
who may Abbott into a bed and beating
orther Kane but not in not in the usual
way so that's that's you know that the
imagery there is pretty phenomenal
and pretty hilarious and then I thought
president Trump and I thought yes that
happened that's the thing I'm you know
my views of Trump I have not been shy
about my views of Trump in the past as I
said in the opener here when Donald
Trump has to change as a man in order
for me to him to earn my support as
president of the United States he didn't
earn my vote because the evidence that I
saw did not suggest he was a man worthy
of my vote now he has the opportunity to
to earn my support by doing all the
things that he promised that he would do
and avoiding all the things that he
promised he would do also and actually
being a good president so we'll see how
that turns out also I'd like to see him
ascend to the character that is
necessary for a Republican President of
the United States I still care about
character in a Republican president and
I'd like to see Donald Trump become that
I'd like to see Donald Trump change as a
human being whether he does or not is up
to him and I will make my judgments of
that based on whether he does or not but
I don't think never Trump was the big
loser last night in the sense that I
didn't vote for Hillary I didn't want
Hillary to win and my agenda has been
always the same which was holds whoever
is in power to the fire when it comes to
conservative principles so here are the
real losers last night number one
Hillary Wow Wow okay so the big untold
story of this election there are a lot
of lies that are being passed around
already about this election a lot of bad
lessons that are being learned for
example the idea that Donald Trump drove
out a mass movement Donald Trump just
absolutely drove out this brand-new vast
mass movement that existed never before
in human history Donald Trump what one
less in terms of one fewer popular votes
in the general election than Mitt Romney
did in 2012 Mitt Romney won about 61
million votes Donald Trump won somewhere
between 59 and 60 million popular votes
and he actually under polled in terms of
absolute votes he under polled Mitt
Romney even in states like Wisconsin so
Romney won something like one point four
million votes in Wisconsin in 2012 and
Trump won one point three million what
that means is that the real story of
this election just in terms of how this
happened the real story of this election
is that Hillary Clinton failed to drive
out nearly 7 million Barack Obama voters
nearly 7 million Barack Obama voters did
not show up for Hillary Clinton and
that's off his high in 2008 remember he
lost something like I think it's 3 to 4
million voters from 2008 to 2012 from 2
8 2 2 2 2016 Hillary Clinton dropped
somewhere in the neighborhood of 10
million Democrat voters that's how
unpopular she is she has been officially
named by the Guinness Book of World
Records the worst politician in the
history of humanity actually so
congratulations to Hillary on that prize
she lost to Obama in 2008 of course she
everybody thought she was gonna win she
lost then she nearly lost in the
primaries to a septuagenarian asylum
escapee and then finally she loses to a
real a reality TV star who for weeks
before the election was hit with the
tape in which he said that he wanted to
grab women by the bleep she lost to that
she is the worst politician in American
history and no one more richly deserves
that title okay second big loser
last night Barack Obama his agenda is
toast his agenda is in serious trouble
Obamacare will be repealed
if Republicans invoke the nuclear option
and can hold their caucus together
Obamacare will be repealed and it will
be replaced which is a great thing there
could be a conservative justice again if
Mitch McConnell does his job always his
I see proposition we could see a tax
decrease we could see some significant
slashes to regulation Barack Obama's
executive orders will likely be walked
back Barack Obama remains popular
personally but he's popular in the same
way that many celebrities it turns out
are popular he's popular as a celebrity
no one likes his policies he doesn't get
to appoint his next of kin he doesn't
get to appoint Hillary to his third term
he is his agenda is essentially tossed
out on its ass and more than that Barack
Obama continued to make the case
throughout his presidency that America
was a deeply racist terrible place
filled by white people who were terribly
deeply racist and awful and America was
a negative force in the world
the best thing about the Trump campaign
in the Trump movement the the thing that
I think is actually worthwhile is that
people were standing up and proudly
saying Bill little did say this
yesterday I think he's right what was on
the hat making America great again was
something that was worthwhile then
America is great the people here are not
racists we are not bad people we don't
deserve the ire of elites like Barack
Obama with scorning us looking down on
us and pretending that they are on a
higher plane while they call us racist
then pander to a racial base it totally
backfired on Obama it totally backfired
on Hillary and Obama's legacy is now on
the table the only legacy he's going to
have after the first hundred days of a
trump administration of Trump does
job the only legacy Barack Obama will
have is that he preceded Donald Trump
and that Barack Obama was unable to win
a third term which means his real only
legacy will be that he was the first
black president which of course is the
only reason the media loved him in the
first place okay then the biggest losers
in all of this bigger than Hillary
bigger than Obama the biggest losers in
all of this obviously the media
obviously the media the media just gets
schlonged in this election cycle and I
will say this people say that it was
Trump that ruined the media I don't
think that's right I think the media
ruined the media I think the media
ruined the media in 2012 when they took
a fundamentally decent man Mitt Romney
and called him a racist sexist bigoted
homophobe and then in 2016 they said the
same things about Trump and it just
didn't wash people said you called Mitt
Romney that and we don't believe you we
think that that was a lie you have no
credibility whatsoever Bill Maher said
this we played it on tape the other day
and the media had no credibility all of
their talk about racist sexist bigotry
homophobia all of it just fell apart it
fell apart in their faces they called
wolf too many times nobody believes
anything they have to say there was a
poll yesterday - exit poll showed 76% of
the people who voted thought the media
were more interested in making money
than they weren't telling the truth when
that's the case the media have lost all
power in our elections and that is a
grand and glorious thing and I do have
to thank Donald Trump for consistently
ripping on the media now sometimes he's
ripping on them even when they were
telling the truth but the fact that
people don't trust the media overall is
a good thing considering the leftist
bias inherent in the media and that was
so obviously on display final big losers
of the night Senate Democrats Senate
Democrats have serious troubles now so
the idea here was the tenant Democrats
were going to gain a majority and they
be able to stymie a president Trump they
don't the only seats that Republicans
hend up losing are Mark Kirk and
Illinois and maybe Kelly Ayotte a New
Hampshire that one is still a little bit
too close to call they end up retaining
their Senate majority that's horrible
news for the Democrats cuz in 2018 there
are five count them five vulnerable
Democrat seats in the Senate if
Republicans win anywhere near that
number they suddenly have a dominant
majority in the Senate and Chuck Schumer
doesn't have a lot of power and I will
say Chuck Schumer is a very smart
political operator Chuck Schumer is
going to create consolidated force
against the Republican majority
Republican majorities have a nasty habit
of splintering because they're always
gangs of eight and people who want to
run for president who want to stake out
their own ground
but if McConnell can hold fast hahaha if
McConnell can hold fast then you're
looking at just a devastating night for
Senate Democrats so here's the deal
Donald Trump has no excuse not to
deliver on all the promises that he's
made none he has he all the promises are
on the table
he should be delivering on all the
promises I want to see Obamacare
repealed I want to see the conservative
justice prove me wrong prove me wrong I
said and I said during the primaries and
during the general I did not trust
Donald Trump to do these things and I
want to see him prove me wrong and I
will be the happiest man on earth I will
really be happy i when I say I want to
see him prove me wrong I don't mean that
facetiously I would love nothing better
than for Donald Trump to turn out to
shock me and shock the world again and
end up being the second coming of Ronald
Reagan being a wonderful conservative
president and making the country better
for everybody I think that would be a
wonderful wonderful thing for the
country wonderful for the Republican
Party I do think that we're gonna have
to you know take a little bit of care in
the lessons that we've learned from this
election cycle because we have a habit
of jumping to the wrong lessons in
various election cycles in this one it's
a single data point right and we're
gonna learn a lot from that single data
point already some of the bad lessons
that I'm hearing are things like polls
are stupid
no the polls in Wisconsin were off the
polls in Michigan were off the polls in
Pennsylvania were off the polls were
right on in Ohio they're right on in
Florida though right on North Carolina
they're right on in New Hampshire
they're right on they were right on in
most of the country they were off in a
lot of these places because they assumed
that Hillary would not have the massive
voter drop-off that she had the
electorate in this election cycle is d+
for for a four-year election cycle for a
presidential election cycle that is
unheard of normally to D +8 normally to
but the national polling was right on
the money the polling average had them
had added about three percent split with
a three percent margin of error hillary
ends up winning the popular vote by
somewhere around one percent so what
that means is that all of this talk
about suddenly Bill Mitchell is a poll
expert because he called the Trump was
gonna win no sometimes you sometimes the
broken clock is right and Bill Mitchell
is certainly a broken clock he was right
that does not mean that all polls should
be thrown out it sort of reminds me of
in baseball in baseball for baseball
fans there's something called
sabermetrics and that's the idea that
you study statistics when you when you
picked the players on your team but when
you get to the play
sometimes there are teams that win that
are not sabermetric we build are not
mathematically built and the idea is
that the sample size is just too small
for us to tell it presidential elections
only happened once every four years so
the idea that stats don't matter because
we had a Black Swan election that seems
like the wrong lesson to learn and a
dangerous lesson to learn the lesson you
don't need a ground game he's a stupid
lesson especially because number one the
RNC clearly did have a ground game and
number two because you're going to need
a ground game when you have a candidate
who doesn't have 100% name recognition
and billions of dollars in free media
coverage other other things that people
are learning from this you can focus
solely and completely on the white vote
that's a mistake
Trump has an absolutely wonderful
opportunity now to reach out to new
constituency he's the president that
means he can reach out in a really
significant way you should continue to
reach out to black communities you want
8% of the black vote which was more than
Mitt Romney's 5% of the black vote he
won 29% of the Hispanic vote which was
more than Mitt Romney's share of the
Hispanic vote which is absolutely
shocking and demonstrates the wild
unpopularity of Hillary Clinton he has
to reach out to those constituencies he
has to reach out to young people young
people voted heavily for Hillary Clinton
the reason I say this is because not not
to take away from from victory but to
note that this is not going to be the
last election ever and demographics are
continuing to shift away from older
white voters even if this even if older
white voters represented the outsized
the outsize share of Trump voters that
drove them over the top on all of this
so those are my basic thoughts on the on
the election cycle but I want to go
through some of the details before we
get to all of that let's say hello to
our sponsors over at trunk club.com
so trunk club comm if you're looking for
fantastic clothes like really well
tailored well crafted clothes and you
want somebody to help you out you need
basically a personal stylist that's what
trunk club does so you coordinate with
your own personal stylist when you go to
trunk club.com slash bed and you type in
your measurement you share your likes
and dislikes and trunk club will send
you a trunk of clothing straight to your
door handpicked by a personal stylist
you can text with the stylist they'll
tell you what you have in your wardrobe
that matches the things that they want
to send you and then you can take a look
and you send the you send the clothes
back that you don't want you keep the
ones that you do you can also if you're
in cities like Dallas New York LA
Chicago DC or Charleston you can go to
their trunk club book club houses which
are super cool I went to the one in LA
and actually I
no stylist will median spend a fair bit
of time with you you're getting to know
kind of what you want in your fashion
they have for both men and women its
trunk club.com slash Ben its trunk
club.com / Ben to become part of trunk
club I I think the product is fantastic
I have a pair of jeans and a jacket from
them spend my own money on it because I
think their product is so good and
because they do a wonderful job of
tailoring they'll even tailor by the way
your clothes if you bring your clothes
to them for like a 15 dollar fee they'll
tailor it for you as well so that's
trunk club comm / Ben alrighty so when
Donald Trump wins last night in what is
easily easily the biggest election
shocker in the history of the nation it
is by far the biggest election shopper
in the history of the nation this would
make the fifth time in American
presidential history somebody loses the
popular vote but wins the electoral
college it happened in 1824 it happened
in 1876 it happened in 1888 and it
happened in 2000 with george w bush and
then it happened again last night
it is interesting not a lot of
discussion about the popular vote versus
the electoral college because Hillary
was so widely expected to win and
underperformed Trump got up and he gave
a victory speech and I think that there
there are a few things that are that are
that we're gonna analyze as we continue
on the show in just a minute we're gonna
analyze some of the lessons from this
whether the lessons are right or wrong
as I say what kind of president is Trump
actually gonna be we're gonna try and
read some tea leaves on that because
we're gonna have to see which support
base he decides to cater to we're gonna
talk about the the absolutely delicious
media reaction because the media just oh
my goodness gracious they lost their
ever loving minds and it was quite
beautiful and we'll talk about also some
stuff I like and stuff I hate but in
order to get all that you have to go
over to Daley wired.com and subscribe $8
a month will bring you to Daley wire
calm then you can be part of the first
of all you get our why our site free of
ads if you get if you get the
subscription that's a Lee Weyer calm if
you get an annual subscription then you
get my book sign my new book true
allegiance signed which is exciting for
you because absolutely it's a keepsake
that you want to hand down to your
grandchildren plus you got to be part of
the mail back in a couple days you get
clave in this show and we're adding new
goodies all the time at daily wire.com
so go ahead and check that out we are
the largest conservative podcast in the
nation
you